one of Facebook's early investors is
urging users to wake up to what he calls
the dark side of social media longtime
tech investor Roger McNamee advised
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg in the
early years of the company he is now the
author of sucked waking up to the
Facebook catastrophe McNamee argues
Facebook as the threat to democracy
public health and users privacy McNamee
writes about how he became convinced
that Facebook is quote terrible for
America and needed to change or be
changed
Facebook is responding by saying it has
changed Roger Magnum he joins us now for
an interview interview you'll see first
on CBS this morning good morning John
it's great to be back thank you for
being here with us wow that is a
condemnation and it's Mark Zuckerberg
15th anniversary this is quite a present
he's getting catastrophe why so John
we've all trusted technology for really
good reasons for the last 50 or 60 years
because every new piece of technology
made our lives better the problem is
that Facebook and Google have taken
advantage of that and they've created
products that essentially prey on the
weakest elements of our psychology to
create first habits and then addictions
and then they didn't take the steps to
safeguard us from what bad actors could
do and so you've seen a really long list
of bad things happening on Facebook and
Google that were fundamentally because
they let the users find all the problems
they don't do any preparation and the
real challenge we face now is that new
generations of technology like Alexa
with the whole Internet of Things and
like artificial intelligence are coming
and those make the danger much greater
so we need to talk about it right now
just have a national conversation
understand the issues and that is why I
wrote something and given the scandals
over the past two years trust and a
company has gone down revenue however
has gone up and they've actually seen
more users come back to the company in
the u.s. in particular what does that
tell you well what it tells me is that
Facebook created this amazing platform
there's really never been anything like
it for advertisers they have essentially
everybody on there and they give you the
ability to target very specifically the
same things that allowed the Russians to
interfere in the brexit referendum
UK and our elections also allow
advertisers to reach exactly the people
they want to reach when I want to sell
my book I advertise on Facebook and
Instagram because they are the place to
reach people so I'm not surprised that
the business is great but that's not the
argument I want to have I just want to
have a conversation about the future of
our children we just saw last week
Facebook was accused in one case
successfully legal challenge with
respect to essentially taking advantage
of minors with in one case credit-card
charges related to games and in the
other case a product that spied on all
their usage and Roger they clearly don't
seem to want to have a conversation with
you and you sound like in some respects
a scorned lover who you had an inside
track with Cheryl and Mark you say you
say that you introduced them and now
they're not listening to you and my
question is why should they listen to
you well they don't have to listen to me
the point here is maybe I'm the wrong
messenger and that I think is very clear
relative to Cheryl and mark and that's
fine what I want to do is have a
conversation the substance of the issues
but you've had no dealings with the
company in over ten years well you know
that's not entirely correct I've not met
with them personally for ten years but I
do well there are the ones you say ideal
look you haven't had a cannoli that's
right yeah but I deal with the product
constantly and the key thing is what I'm
talking about here is not about me it's
about the issues that Facebook and
Google and other internet platforms the
issues that they're putting on America
the things they're putting on the whole
world because everybody is there and
we're vulnerable when we're on those
platforms they you know here's a very
simple way to think about it when you go
into a Terms of Service on an internet
contract you ever read it it would take
you you know in I think what's now seven
or eight years ago they somebody went
and checked and would take you 78 days
to read every single one it applies to
many companies let's allow Facebook
because they gave us a statement they
said we take the criticism seriously and
over the past two years we've
fundamentally changed how we operate to
better protect the safety and security
of people using Facebook let me ask you
this though do you have proof evidence
that in cases where they have been told
that they are allowing group
foreign countries others to siphon off
personal information that they haven't
acted quickly who made when they were
made aware one of the most basic ones
was the Department of Housing Urban
development's cited Facebook for
advertising tools that allow
discrimination and violation the Fair
Housing Act Facebook claimed that they
had fixed the product and then
ProPublica did a series of studies that
showed that they had not done so the
Federal Trade Commission went after
Facebook for essentially improperly
failing to disclose to users what was
happening to their data and Facebook did
not in fact follow through and do what
the Federal Trade Commission asked
that's how Cambridge analytical happened
so this is in fact a repeated problem
and you know there's been one great
author the Zeynep to fetch e at
university of north carolina who
characterizes Facebook as a 15 year
apology tour because their strategy is
to maintain a black box where we can't
really inspect what's going on and then
just apologize and promise to do better
and my point here is that that these
products are so important that we need
to have these investigations we need to
recognize that well they need to but
you've raised some questions but you if
you even bet listen you have no evidence
just spidey-sense on why they should
change and that you're operating on
hypothesis and not real evidence but
you're right you've raised some issues
there should be a conversation and if in
mind they say a political power that
dominates this country and around the
world they're not elected and the whole
point of Zuck is to give you as a voter
and as a citizen the United States of
America an opportunity to understand the
questions and the issues all right Roger
McNamee very provocative title to duck
goes on sale tomorrow